en este curso aprenderás cómo hacer que
tus páginas web sean interactivas
empezaras usando html y css en páginas
web sencillas
después les agregaremos javascript para
cambiarlas cómo hacer un juego de
palabras una presentación de
diapositivas una galería muy cargada o
una aplicación de dibujo puedes hacer
casi todo lo que has visto en la web
vamos a usar el lenguaje javascript para
hacer todo eso y tal vez te sientas
confundidos y antes aprendiste
javascript y lo usabas en una forma
distinta verás javascript fue
originalmente creado para usarlo con los
navegadores y hacer que las páginas web
fueran interactivas pero en la
actualidad puedes usar javascript en
muchos entornos distintos en los
procesos internos del servidor que
procesan las páginas web y almacenan
información de usuarios o para escribir
comandos para la manipulación de
imágenes o para procesar datos en una
hoja de cálculo o incluso para controlar
robots
si aprendes javascript en can academy
entonces puedes aprenderlo en el
ambiente de processing leyes para hacer
dibujos y animaciones si lo aprendes en
otro lado como cauda academy entonces lo
aprenderás con un ambiente simple de
líneas de comandos cada ambiente tiene
su propio conjunto de variables globales
y funcionalidad
por ejemplo en proceso y hay muchas
funciones para hacer dibujos y
animaciones como field el leeds mouse
click y text en un ambiente de páginas
web los navegadores facilitan una serie
de funciones para hacer que las páginas
sean interactivas como get elements by
the set
interval y advent listener aprenderás
todo sobre esas funciones en este curso
y más y podrás utilizarlas en tus
páginas web para convertirlas en
asombrosas experiencias interactivas